this is the nerve center of Islamic
States transnational grooming operation
a social media phenomenon spanning the
globe urging that vulnerable to take up
jihad and to travel to Syria our
cameraman risked his life to film these
exclusive pages this internet center is
the preserve of foreign fighters working
shifts according to their nationality
and world time zones based here in al
raqqa is where these gunmen maintain
order on the streets and enforce their
strict interpretation of Islam it is
here that the newly groomed arrivals to
Syria have brought amongst the British
teenagers hadiza Sultana Shamima begun
and Amira Abbar say three London
schoolgirls who came here in February
they were met looked after and taught
how to behave by this woman she calls
herself
um Asma there was very happy to come to
Syria in Raqqa and meet most people of
dyes there was very very happy and with
a laughing smiling smiling and speaking
we are very happy when we come to here
and we like this love the world Muslim I
think that did they say why they came I
said no I didn't bother you think they
are come two years two to living Arabic
or the world Muslim Quran so they came
to to understand Islam and to learn
about and why he come to here and I said
you know they are was very happy they
needed to learn is that right they
didn't really understand that to be to
remain covered and to not take your
I think she is no but little about the
word Muslim how how he how we are live
living in in world Muslim how she little
nope but of course that's because
they're from England I said I know I
know in England in Europe and in Europe
we all have a free free for everything
but she she
they are won't come to Syria so they saw
coming to Syria is a way of finding
their freedom but I'm sure they are they
are was very happy to come to Syria very
happy I think it's very interesting to
him today me
Massimo says the girls were groomed to
come here but were just three from as
many as fifty a month many of them
British he claims who also came to Syria
they're now being trained for special
missions this yeah this girl Allah now
because they are very younger she wants
they want four or three months to start
so not yet they're still training and do
you think they will go back to home
never do you think they will die in
Syria
I think you will die in Syria or Iraq I
think
are they now famous in Isis no just
normal girls no because we have in it
though in - very little a lot of of
girls any British or Germany or French
what sort of number how many 10 100 200
the number is up there every month up
down up down up them asthma is one of
the most senior members of Islamic state
ever to leave she brings with her
confirmation of a sophisticated grooming
plan to specifically target young
foreigners and to bring them to Syria to
train and to fight but she confirms for
the very first time a plan by Islamic
state to send those same young
foreigners back to the homes they came
from to carry out attacks a long-term
Islamic state member she's clear just
what her fate would be as a traitor if
she were to return she's on the run now
she can never rest so they know that
you've escaped they are aware that you
have left will they try to come here to
find you every time every day every
second every moment here I'm very afraid
and what's happened to me I mean I think
for example I met any person of having
women in Turkey in the market or
anything she always worried always
watching always always I think about
this every every second every moment my
I'm Fred and the big afraid of my family
in Syria now I want
what's happened with him the fate of
Shamima Khadija and Amira is unclear
finding them in a place where no woman
shows her face is almost impossible
they've come to Syria and disappeared if
they resurface
because Islamic state has let them steal
Ramsey sky news on the turkey-syria
border